sometimes you need a loudspeaker or in
this case microphones to send a strong
message
this is the podcast where we set the
record straight lauren harris and ashley
stobart are friends and now hosts of
their own show they talk about cosmetic
surgery heartbreak but most importantly
online bullying
they both say they've been targeted by
trolls on a forum called tattle life
it describes itself as a place for
commentary and critiques of influencers
if their social media content is
sponsored
lauren and ashley say theirs isn't and
they think the posts on tattlelife go
way beyond the site's own remit
they actually wrote that i was a drug
dealer
that isn't gossip that's serious
allegations that are untrue and that you
can't take back once they're out there
at least on instagram if someone
comments a nasty comment under my
picture you can click on their profile
with this it's completely different they
are hidden behind a computer screen
lauren wondered whether she knew the
people that were writing about her she
became scared to leave the house
i would walk down the street and if
somebody i knew from school would say
hiya i think it's you
it's you you're talking about me
it it made my mental health so bad it
gave me such terrible anxiety
m sheldon also attracted the attention
of some tattle life users she even
installed cameras at her home after
reading posts containing details about
her property
this is the scariest thing it goes into
more than just talking about someone's
appearance it's a privacy and a security
thing
and i don't think anyone should feel
unsafe
ever
em now makes a living as a fashion and
lifestyle blogger she says trolls
shouldn't be able to hide behind
anonymous profiles it would be great if
there was a way that could protect
everyone that meant that people had id
some form of it connected to a social
media account
in a statement tattlelife said we have a
zero tolerance policy towards content
that is hateful abusive and threatening
and we take the privacy of social media
influencers far more seriously than they
do themselves in many cases
we allow commentary critique and praise
of people who choose to monetize their
personal life as a business
anyone can join and post a comment and
we encourage people to report any that
overstep the line people that come to
post abusive or hateful content are
banned
m has spoken to mps publicly about the
abuse she's faced online she says she
was too scared to mention tattle life to
them afraid of facing a backlash from
users but now she wants to speak out and
put the damage they've caused under the
spotlight becky cottrell sky news